[Music]
yeah the boxing thing is crazy fousey's
making a comeback on youtube
so what's what's that about i haven't i
went down this rabbit hole basically he
people are calling him like the dana
white of youtube
you could like wait is he is he like
actually the one promoting and
organizing the fights
nah he uh you could just let this play
without volume but basically in this
video
he goes to a gym
and it's crazy because this gym i didn't
realize they trained him for his last
fight
or this that's where he trained who
that's ten goose boxing i know like i
don't know who
who he fousey remember when he fought
that fight and he lost like horribly
oh yeah so he trained at 10 goose and
um i'm familiar with them just because
uh a comedian i used to roll with like
trains there
and ten goose actually did this event
where they had comedians box each other
it was like
pretty entertaining um and so
fousey went there and he they set up
like a mini tournament with all these
boxers
uh that are like creators as well i
guess or like dudes that want to box
and i this kid alex wasabi like he was
supposed to fight ksi or something
but this video is actually cool because
you could tell all the kids in there
like
they definitely have a passion for
boxing like they really care
uh that kid nick ireland has a
as a [ __ ] gas tank but and they all
train here
i don't know if they all train there but
they all definitely box
um i think that might be his first time
but they're all super young it doesn't
matter
so there's one dude in here i think he's
got the most generic name ever it's like
ryan johnson or something
um that dude
you know i'll spoil this video he wins
the whole thing
okay but you knew he was gonna win the
whole thing because
after uh this kid doesn't box he just
boxed bryce hall for a round and i
i think he got touched up i could i
couldn't follow that whole [ __ ] man that
yeah this was all over all the drama
[ __ ] like tick-tock pages and everything
it doesn't dramatives
ryan johnson okay he you knew he was
going to win the whole thing because he
did his first fight
and uh they were like man you got heart
man you pulled it out and he looks to
the camera and he goes
that was all god right there you're like
oh yeah this motherfucker's gonna kill
everybody in there that dude when an
athlete talks about
god did that for me those are the ones
you should be scared to death of
because why because they're the ones
that have
this switch that goes beyond humanity
yeah like they're able to put themselves
in another
zone entirely yeah like art and santa
you know one of the greatest f1 drivers
ever
that dude you know he would say like oh
it's by the power of god i can drive
this way it's like oh this dude doesn't
even
screw yeah maintenance on the ship it's
just annoying
he doesn't even drive thinking about his
family or his kids this dude drives like
i'm doing this for him
it's like for the big man it's like you
if
a before a fight a dude just goes like
it's like yeah you should be horrified
okay i get it you know
and like uh shouldn't you be more scared
of someone that has nothing to live for
nah i i think it's the ones that like
like
when they have that ultimate faith to
the lord
because they hit that fourth wind where
it's like
just give it to me lord and it just
comes from somewhere else and it's like
oh this is what i was put here to do
punch right through yeah exactly
yeah pull out their heart something just
came over
here you go god my offering
that's what that's why you all romero
was so scary because he called himself
the soldier of god oh yeah
and after he'd literally murdered
someone in the ring he'd do this like
like north east southwest [ __ ] where he
would just salute the air
like he just it's like that's scary
like who yeah right who are you
you're on the ground spirit dog you're
on the ground like
and this dude is over your body like
mission complete
bury him now he's gone he's out of here
so i think you know jake he did pick the
perfect opponent because
that's who all these guys should be
afraid of is the ryan johnson's in this
game
like i think jake if he wins he might
win a couple more
and i feel like he's gonna pick a guy
with that mentality yeah just thinking
like yeah
it's go time and jake's gonna be the
presser like you [ __ ] [ __ ] the
fight game whatever and that dude's
gonna be the other side like
i've eaten beans for 30 days
[Music]
presser's gonna be like scary awkward
yeah so how do you feel going into this
fight
i just give all the glory to god and
whatever happens in there is what's
gonna happen
[Music]
and i'm who you're jake no jake okay
yeah or you could be dude i'm literally
gonna slam your head
into the ground dude i'm gonna slam it
up your own ass
cheeks dawg i mean
that's that's not the plan that god has
outlined for me
so why you keep talking about god man
glory to the greatest man i fight for
different reasons
this is going to be
why does your breath smell like beans
bro
i don't know i mean just yeah so this
kid ryan johnson he
has in this [ __ ] like he's
he has crazy like fight iq like in the
moment
like he'll just be ducking these dudes
and then he dropped that kid nick
ireland and then
immediately that kid hits the mat and
he's just going wow
the whole ring is like yeah this way we
cut this one short
dude the best part about all this the
best part is that pull up a ryan johnson
video
oh wait wait let this play and then
we're gonna do a ryan john
super comfortable in there too
he's dodging
who is that against um
rich ireland
[Applause]
it does it again he flicks that his jab
and then he
tells it too much
[Applause]
that was the craziest round yeah
you